it was good
what's up guys i'm cute and this is root
and today we're going to be trying baby
food for the first time
you excited rue is getting restless so
we're going to get it started
right now roo come back
all right okay so the first thing we're
trying today
what a rule hold up boy hold up boy
hold up the first thing we're trying
today is chicken
let's see everyone likes it he looks
like he has no problem okay
oh
oh okay
oh it's not that bad
i'll give you a little more
[Music]
bru you like it high five
good boy you love this
okay the next one we're trying is peter
rabbit organics
apple pea and spinach you like apples
you like peas
like spinach okay
let's see this one right now
oh this is good
oh you don't like it yeah
you like it we just want mine
no i think it's great okay
i think you're gonna like this one the
next one we're eating is wild caught
coho salmon made with organic butternut
squash and beet
[Music]
i bet okay
he likes it for sure oh my god
[Music]
you like it oh he loves it
oh my god okay
i don't think i could do this for i
think i can do this one here i'll give
you a little bit of money
oh this [ __ ] stinks oh my gosh
okay
[Music]
okay oh
bro you went in like no oh
this for me this ain't it eat the rest
okay so the next one we have is happy
baby
softly crafted sweet potato for stage
one baby i'm not sure what that means
but
i think we qualify right let's see
he loves it
all right you got your own right there
look
i feel like you put some cinnamon and
some sugar in here
a banger
high five it feels good it was good
okay so this one i think is going to be
fire this is
happy baby clearly crafted bananas and
strawberries i like banana strawberry
yogurt
i think this is probably going to taste
similar roo is already pretty interested
let's see what he thinks
[Music]
oh i don't think he likes it this oh
this smells
good oh yeah
okay i got it everyone that i like root
does not like
is that how it is eat it
[Music]
yeah this is good i eat this whole thing
right now you want to wait away from me
[Music]
all right so we're back in rues
territory with 100
grass-fed beef made with organic
kale and sweet potato two things that
he likes beef and sweet potato this is
gonna be
disgusting as well i can tell um
yeah so hopefully i don't throw up i'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it
enjoy it looks disgusting
oh my god he finished with a price
[Music]
i don't smell it oh okay okay
oh my god
[Music]
okay okay
um
[Music]
all right last one we have
apples and blueberries organic baby food
still stage two six months plus
apparently you might not like this
though you're a little iffy by the last
fruit mix so
let's see i think i like it i'm gonna
love it
what do you think oh
this is amazing it's like apple sauce
this is good i mean this whole thing
eat yours here
[Music]
okay we're done um this is amazing
clearly roo does not like it and uh
yeah that was it
high five he's mad at me
okay i'll give you chicken high five
high five high five let's see if i'm
getting a high five me first salmon
[Music]
you